You're my girl.
I turned you in.
I'm pregnant.
So what comes next?
Nothing good.
-What do you want?
-Oh, relax, sweetheart.
I just need you to call
your lady friends over
so we can all have...
a little talk.
We take our kids
to PF Chang's,
and we take orange slices
to soccer games.
And when bad things
happen to good people,
everyone else goes crazy.
I keep thinking
about what you said,
about being a basic bitch,
and whatnot.
That's not exactly
what I said--
Maybe there's something
you could help me out with.
You know the tradition
is Jordans
over a phone line, right?
I only had pumps.
Fair enough.
Okay, come on.
You can do it. Get it.
What do you want?
They're gonna wanna know
what someone like me
is doing
with someone like you.
What are you doing
with someone like me?
That family
you're always talking about?
Go home to them.
What me and you had is done.
Over.
What are you doing,
Elizabeth?
I don't know.
I just want it to be over.
Okay.
Let's end it.
It's all right.
It's okay.
You did your best.
It turns out,
we've got a mutual friend.
Yeah, I'm gonna need you
to take care of him.
That's insane!
Is it?
I can't just murder someone.
I'm not a psychopath.
Not easy
being the boss, huh?
Excuse me, miss?
I just need…
service.
You can't tell people
you're my business partner.
Well...
what do you want
to call us, then?
Let's just
not label it, okay?
You look good
behind that desk.
Thank you.
You'd look
so much better on top of it.
I'm gonna take a shower.
You should go.
It's over.
What are you doing here?
I tried calling.
I blocked your number.
Damn, that's cold.
I'm about
to be arrested for murder.
That sucks.
And you couldn't
return a text?
Hey, I don't work
while on vacation.
That's what I am? Work?
Pretty much, yeah.
You put everything on me.
The money,
the dealership--
It's not easy
being king, right?
You put it all on me,
so it's never on you.
Nothing's ever on you.
Well, now you've got
a bigger problem, don't you?
You think he's my problem?
So, put on
your big girl panties
and take care of it.
He's not my problem.
Shut your mouth, bitch,
okay, and just handle it--
Lung.
Spleen.
Shoulder.
You're my girl,
you know, so...
I'm gonna
take it easy on you.
I'll do it myself.
I'm pregnant.
Congratulations.
Anything else?
Paternity test.
Thank you so much.
Can I get a shot of tequila?
You might wanna
slow down, yeah?
We never got to toast.
One for
my baby daddy here, too.
I lost it.
So, what comes next?
Nothing good.
They want you.
Yeah, I figured
one of them was coming.
So, dinner was...
fun,
yeah?
Parts of it.
Please don't hurt my kids.
I ain't gonna hurt nobody.
But I turned you in.
So, your tag
is really coming along.
I've got
a really good campaign team.
I told you
you didn't need him.
If you need something,
darling,
all you've got to do is ask.
He's your brother.
Cousin.
Family.
He's in our way.
You know the best part
about all this?
What? Not the city salary?
You work for me now.
You got it, boss.